gigantisch und wir kommen jetzt zu ihnen
eine Sache aber noch ergänzen genau
genau ich würde nämlich sagen wir haben
keinem das ist ein Schimmer auf was wir
da hinsteuern wir befinden uns jetzt
schon im Herbst Nebel wie es nennen
würde die Inzidenzen sinken im Moment
vielleicht weil auch schon in vielen
Bundesländern Herbstferien sind
andererseits gibt es auch sinken
Inzidenzen fast zeitgleich beginnend in
Italien Österreich und Frankreich man
fragt wie wird die woher kommt denn das
das kann halt nicht an den Deutschen
Herbst werden liegen das kann auch nicht
an der deutschen Vorsicht Liegen oder im
deutschen Maßnahmen oder nichtmaßnahmen
von daher wir sind halt immer noch an
dem Punkt nach fast drei Jahren wo wir
eigentlich überhaupt nicht wissen was
nächste Woche nächsten Monat im nächsten
Jahr auf uns wartet wenn die sommerwelle
zum Beispiel kam komplett überraschend
da haben auch die Virologen nicht
mitgerechnet die reden immer von
saisonalen Effekten das im Herbst
natürlich die Zahlen steigen das
erwarten wir aber auf einmal eine
sommerwelle kommt völlig unerwartet er
ist auch völlig
jeder dann unvermitteln wir
zusammengebrochen wir wissen es halt
nicht in Vorwurf den ich der Politik
machen würde ist dass wir mutwillig viel
weniger wissen als dass wir tun könnten
ein Beispiel ist es gab im März 2020
ganz am Anfang schon ein
wissenschaftlichen Vorschlag ein
repräsentatives Testen zu machen das hat
den großen Vorteil dass wir ein genaues
Bild haben über das Infektionsgeschehen
und auch insbesondere darüber wer sich
infiziert und wo er sich infiziert wir
wissen bis heute nicht ob Busse und
Bahnen wirklich gefährlich sind ob
Supermärkte wirklich gefährlich sind das
wird einfach das behauptet zu wissen und
wir vermuten dass das vermutlich
eine Ansteckung erforderlich ist wenn
man einen Bus und an einer Bahn fährt
weil wir es auch von früher auf einer
Grippe so kennen wissen tun wir es nicht
hätten wir ein repräsentatives testen
könnten wir genau gucken stecken sich
Pendler überproportional an wo stecken
Sie sich an sind das junge alte da haben
wir viel zu wenig Informationen drüber
so ein Vorschlag lag im März 2020 vor
heute Abend wieder man weiß das noch
nicht man weiß das noch nicht wir sind
doch nicht mehr im Jahr 2020 oder doch
doch doch es gab ganz lange zum Beispiel
ganz lange
zurück in der Zeit als wir über
Altenheim und Krankenhäuser geredet
haben werden
schutzfolderable Gruppen im Moment
gerade unter den alten steigende Zahlen
wieder also die Schützen die vulnerable
nach wie vor nicht es gab halt immer
andere Länder wie Amerika mit so beiden
haben die Pandemie längst für beendet
erklärt auch viele andere Länder
genau
in der ganzen Welt in Corona also die
Virus so sehen wie in Deutschland naja
also wir haben halt nach wie vor 10.000
Fälle jeden Tag von denen im Moment ein
ganz ganz großer Teil ein
überproportional Teil über 60 Jahre alt
ist also von denen werden auch ein eine
gewisse Anzeigen gewisse Anteil im
Krankenhaus waren und auf
Intensivstationen und wir möchten alle
dass die Intensivstation
die können das machen wie sie wollen
aber ich sag halt nur wenn die Medizin
mir sagt und Medizin Manager mir sagen
wir brauchen zehn Prozent frei
Intensivbetten in Deutschland um
reaktionsfähig zu sein um halt wenn
irgendwas passiert handeln zu können und
wir sind aktuell wir waren lange bei 15%
in diesem Jahr den aktuell bei 12%
Tendenz
die Leute sich infizieren und
ignoriert zum Beispiel völlig noch mal
wir sind von 50 15 auf 12%
zurückgekommen was die freien Betten
angeht zehn Prozent ist die kritische
Grenze
genau aber das ist auch eine Sache da
bin ich mir sicher ob wir es austesten
was dann wirklich passiert
Amerika fahrlässig sind wir in
Deutschland wieder im Jahr 2020
meine meine Perspektive darauf ich meine
Joe Biden kann viel erzählen wenn der
Tag lang
ich habe schon den Eindruck dass in
Deutschland man sich sehr gerne jetzt
noch an den an den corona-maßnahmen und
an Corona als Thema so ein bisschen so
ein bisschen festhält einfach ich glaube
wenn man dass ich da politisch auch dran
gewöhnt hat und das ist eben auch meine
mein großes Problem in den USA ist in
Anführungszeichen alles viel schlimmer
gewesen auf der anderen Seite wenn man
dann mal genau hinschaut war es auch
nicht so schlimm wie es
propagiert würde ich meine dieses Schiff
das oder angeschafft haben das stand
auch leer also haben sie denn zum Ende
dieses großen corona-blocks die wir
heute haben Abend hatten vielleicht
einen Wunsch der die Seiten so ein
bisschen auch vereint die selber machen
ich würde mir tatsächlich wünschen dass
man dass der Staat nicht mehr im
Blindflug arbeitet das was gerade gesagt
wurde zum zum Thema dass man gezielt
testet und nicht nur irgendwelchen
Infektionsketten man muss es ja sagen
ihnen hinterher rennt mit dem frommen
Wunsch die dadurch zu unterbrechen hat
ja blendend funktioniert
dass man ja wir haben das in den enormen
Kontrollverfahren vor zwei Jahren im
einstweiligen busverfahren angestoßen
haben haben wir exakt das vorgetragen
wir haben gesagt wir wissen wir wissen
nichts dass das der Zahlen wo es den wir
haben der ist in keine Richtung und
irgendeine Art und Weise aussagekräftigt
kein Blindflug mehr mit den empfinden
wahrscheinlich alle am Tisch so und wir
sind gleich zurück dann aber nicht mehr
mit Corona sondern mit dem
Fachkräftemangel